como se esperaba no aportó demasiados
datos nuevos el estudio conjunto de la
organización mundial de la salud china
sobre los orígenes del coronavirus
concluyó que probablemente el virus se
había transmitido de murciélagos a
humanos a través de otro animal los
autores de los informes no descartaron
otras teorías y si son life start éste
es sólo el primer comienzo solo hemos
arañado la superficie de este conjunto
muy complejo de estudios que deben
realizarse y hemos señalado muchos
estudios adicionales que deberían
realizarse a partir de ahora formaban el
equipo concluyó que si bien no era
imposible una fuga en un laboratorio de
buján era la hipótesis menos probable un
hallazgo sobre el cual la o ms planteó
interrogantes el director de la entidad
indicó que el equipo había tenido
dificultades para acceder a algunos
datos y que se requería más
investigación estados unidos y sus
aliados hicieron eco en una declaración
conjunta
lamentaron que el estudio se retrasó
significativamente y no tuvo acceso a
datos originales completos el equipo de
la o ms pasó cuatro semanas en luján
enero y febrero más de un año después de
que aparecieran los primeros casos la
investigación se retrasó debido a que
china restringió el acceso al
laboratorio y al mercado de alimentos
donde se identificaron los primeros
contagios en humanos el equipo concluyó
que el rol que había tenido el mercado
era incierto también juzgó que la teoría
de beijing que plantea que el virus no
se originó en china sino que se importó
en alimentos congelados es muy poco
probable